just take the jar
so
i chose nick because i knew he'd make a
nice ukemi and it'll look good but most
people
would do this
he
well i couldn't go because there was
somebody standing there and
well he didn't really throw me and
so
to
really to be a good uk you've got to
have a little bit of flexibility you
know so even if you don't want to take
the ukemi
because you know you're getting older or
you're stiff or you know whatever your
reason is you've got to
you've got to if you're okay likes
taking highfalls stick with that person
because they are the best
thing you can get because you'll look
good you'll feel good they feel good but
it's not really working
and cytosensei when you see him do this
and it all looks good it's because he's
got a good okay
and and i want to just tell you about um
anywhere when you're training day after
day
everything starts to hurt i mean
everything even if you're in super fit
condition
joints hurt
your body's got perhaps scuffed on the
mat
it hurts so what you do is you go into
self-protection mode because you've
signed up to be an iwama you've got to
put up with it so you go into
self-protection mode so it's easier to
take ukemi
than it is to sort of keep going i don't
want to go because what happens is by
you not going or blending
they start trying to throw you harder
so you actually get more injuries
so what i want to say today is if you
go
at least flow at least you know try and
blend with it even if you don't want to
take the the high fall you know
just just try to
the technique is to gather a little
turn it past his body we're not going to
do this i'm just showing you because
it's the west
okay
so
you can't see the power that's coming
out of me
all you can see is a nice ukemi
and i know that if nick doesn't want to
go so this time you don't want to go
he's there but at least look
everything's right now this crossover
i remember pat hendrick scentsy she said
it's the hardest who chemi to take
because you've got crossed arms you've
not got an arm that you can put down so
she said it's better to do the
the ukemi
up here around the joe
and that takes a lot for nuki to be able
to do that
but you see how he
he went round the jar up here
i was watching a
youtube video of someone
and they're doing it like this
and with that joe down there
this person could break his uh
collarbone
so you so
so you'll notice when i finished i was
there and that's where he goes around so
i'm only telling you because tattoo dory
there's not a lot of feedback you know
you might sort of like
go like that you might not get a lot of
buzz back
so it's uki's job to put a lot into this
all right
so it's hooke's job to put a lot into
this
okay
i'm hitting him with something different
i'm
i can't hit him with that
but you know it's like from here it's
going
oh
all right so
you put the power
of the path of non resistance
so when you draw him in
don't try and take too much
and then it punches
from here